chemin roxane fin d'après-midi ils sont
déjà plus d'une centaine à avoir
traversé la frontière plus de 13 mille
demandeurs d'asile ont emprunté ce
passage de janvier à mai du jamais vu
avant l'arrivée de l'été
finalement réuni les réjouissances
seront de courte durée pour cette
famille colombienne les formulaires de
vaccination ne seraient pas en règle
triste et ses soeurs devront patienter
dans ces roulottes de fortune où elles
ont déjà passé deux nuits mouvementées
disant qu'est la verdeur miné le pays
ces
mots que l' agence des services
frontaliers devra ajouter des roulottes
pour répondre à l'afflux qui augmente
leur capacité passera de 2 197 à 477
personnes ils nous ont mis six matches
23 ans a dû fuir le tchad persécuté pour
avoir critiqué le gouvernement
franchement j'ai hyper est ce que je
suis je vais retourner est ce que je
veux mourir ces deux premiers jours au
canada dans une roulotte lui ont laissé
un arrière goût amer à la frontière
c'est la galère franchement c'est pas
facile d'y à kadima rien juste des lieux
et des idées et des draps et puis voilà
c'est la bouffe c'est pas quelque chose
de très résistant le goulot
d'étranglement ce sont les hôtels
réservés par le fédéral et séjours
destinés à une quarantaine de deux
semaines se prolonge combien temps vous
prévoyez rester en mois et demi et la
crise du logement compliquer la sortie
des hôtels un exemple
les demandeurs d'asile sont souvent
dépassés par la lourdeur administrative
quand on est sur le terrain on est un
peu frustré parce que nous on vient avec
un mandat particulier qui celui de les
aider à chercher un logement mais on est
interpellé pour tout ce qui précède ses
démarches la québec accuse ottawa
d'accepter trop de demandeurs d'asile
par rapport à la capacité d'accueil et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on assiste
à l'addition déroula et c'est évidemment
dans des conditions humaines qui sont
certainement discutable les roulottes
ont déjà coûté plus de 7 millions de
dollars et leur facture augmentera avec
l'ajout de nouvelles installations
temporaires il sait jean-philippe use
radio canada c'est bernard de lacolle